Вода з крану, з магазину або бювету.
Чимало жителів Києва в якості водопровідної води не впевнені,
а тому і в будні, і у вихідні біля бюветів вишиковуються черги.
Водоканалу я ніяк не довіряю, бо у них радянські норми залишились
і радянське обладнання. Тому довіряти радянщині ми ніяк не можемо.
Водопровідну ніколи, бо шкіру одразу тягне…
Сьогодні вирішили скористатись бюветною, щоб спробувати якість цієї води,
адже ми набираємо воду в селі і вона у нас дуже якісна.
А цього разу не поїхали в село і не можемо набрати воду, тому спробували бюветну.
Вода, яка тече у київських будинках, має три джерела постачання:
70% береться з Десни, решта - з Дніпра та артезіанських джерел.
Вода змішується, очищується і вже тоді подається в будинки.
Ось у цій лабораторії, що на Дніпровській водопровідній станції,
роблять кінцеві заміри якості дніпровської води перед її подачею.
Це визначення залишкового хлору.
Лідія на станції працює з 80-х років, а саму станцію відкрили ще в далекому 1939-му році.
З тих часів схема очистки води майже не змінилася:
єдиним і ефективним методом знезараження води залишається хлор.
У нас вся виходить відповідно Держсанпіну.
Вода питна.
Вона різна виходить: весною інколи більше коагулянтів,
а влітку - більше хлору і навіть вторичне дохлорування.
Хлор є небезпечною речовиною. Має неприємний запах, може підсушувати шкіру і волосся,
викликати подразнення слизових носа та очей.
Саме на вміст цієї речовини і скаржиться більшість киян.
У Німеччині, приміром, від хлору відмовились кілька десятиліть тому.
Замінити хлор на більш сучасні реагенти та покращити якість води
обіцяв ще у 2014 році Віталій Кличко, коли тільки балотувався в мери столиці.
Коли ти роками п'єш таку воду, це не дуже добре для організму.
Є багато різних напрямків очищення води.
Я думаю, ми маємо їх реалізовувати,
якщо хочемо стати сучасним містом.
Активна модернізація водопровідних насосних станцій почалася три роки тому.
Так, 13 із 14 артезіанських водопровідних насосних станцій Києва
перевели на знезараження води на безпечніший гіпохлорит натрію.
Це покращує запах, присмак та колір води. Втім,
різницю містяни навряд чи відчують, адже сумарно такі станції
складають лише 10% київської води.
Значно важливіші зміни мають відбутися на Дніпровській станції,
яка постачає воду для третини Києва. Тут завершується
будівництво цеху з виробництва діоксиду хлору.
Це сучасніший реагент, яким замість хлору збираються знезаражувати воду.
Він використовується у багатьох містах Європи: у Відні, Нюрнберзі, Варшаві.
Це покращить смакові якості.
Тому що вода і сьогодні безпечна.
Вона відповідає всім нашим нормам законодавства.
Більш того, якісні показники води кращі, ніж в деяких європейських країнах.
Але є вимоги суспільства - запах хлору і ми його прибираємо завдяки новим технологіям.
В Україні з 2010 року якість питної води
визначається Державними санітарними нормами.
Цей документ замінив застарілий радянський ГОСТ
та має максимально наближені до Європейського союзу норми.
У ньому визначено 90 бактеріологічних та фізико-хімічних показників,
за якими встановлюється якість води.
Незважаючи на заяви про повну безпеку вживання води з крана,
кияни часто самотужки перевіряють її якість.
Зазвичай відповідає вода водопровідна нормативному документу.
Але виходячи з наших спостережень,
норма для жорсткості за Держсанпіном - 7, але якщо жорсткість більше 3,5,
то вже споживач скаржиться на накип,
на те, що псується побутова техніка, на накип в чайнику,
наліт на сантехніці і сухість шкіри після купання.
Тому потрібно контролювати воду і додатково доочищати.
Саме високим рівнем жорсткості вода в Києві
відрізняється від води у країнах ЄС. Вона зумовлена
надлишком солей кальцію та магнію, гідрокарбонатів і сульфатів.
Якщо таку воду часто пити, є ризики утворення піску та каменів у нирках.
Можливі й інші побічні ефекти на здоров’я людини, тож аби позбутися цієї жорсткості,
в лабораторії рекомендують воду доочищувати за допомогою фільтрів.
Крім цього, так можна уникнути і забруднень від старих трубопроводів.
Зазвичай це може бути осад, залізо і запах.
Всі відхили від норм небезпечні для організму.
До кінця року в "Київводоканалі" обіцяють запустити завод з діоксиду хлору
і далі перейти до ремонту Деснянської водопровідної станції,
яка постачає 65% води місту. За оптимістичними оцінками,
вже через 2,5 роки Київ повністю відмовитись від використання хлору
для знезараження питної води.
Втім, справді про якісну воду можна буде говорити тоді,
коли вирішуватимуться й інші нагальні проблеми. Наприклад,
заміна трубопроводів та водопровідних систем. Труби в столиці зношені подекуди на 80%.
Влада також має жорсткіше контролювати роботи
комунальних та промислових підприємств, стічні води яких забруднюють річки.